so they put me in order and says man
person moment camera tv
it goes on my god that's amazing
how do you do that i don't know it's
amazing
[Music]
hey there it's martin i'm roman kemp yes
and this
is first impressions the lad bible if i
find out
that [ __ ] stole all of my tigers
i'm gonna i'm gonna come after you and
her
it's a targeting it was my name
it's joe exotico oh
you're either bringing in an airplane or
you're a mine i don't know
stop doing i don't know air traffic
person
thank you bryn oh
you got
thank you them he put me in order and
says man
person moment camera tv
it goes oh my god that's amazing
how do you do that i don't know
it's amazing
little
[Music]
it's not just another day it's another
day to excel baby
it's your friend from the jungle which
is
um the kardashian shut up
no give him them surely what's in there
no
you're not giving the name give it a
name i know is they
who's that what's the name jenner okay
i'm not confuring you cheating sharon
you know the thing is that as much as i
like
um i always got a band called span down
ballet
i like them but i prefer
the rolling stones harry stones is harry
styles
[Music]
is that american dad now
it's the big fella yeah funny tune yes
it's really true
yes i'll give it to you it's
peter griffin foreign
man
but most of the time spending time in
london but real family you know
she's quite posh now that she's who is
your favorite guys
you're here what we're going to do now
we're going to put your penis please
get yourself in there you're doing great
doing
so that was first impressions i'm martin
kemp all right
thanks so much for watching see you soon
thank you so much
you